pero cómo te sientes con tu atuendo creo
que me veo bien es como la pizza malo
pero ya sabes bueno a la vez entienden
lo que digo
[Música]
o esperen debo decir que ustedes se ven
muy bien quería decirles hoy empieces
con eso
porque alguien va a tener que ser el
último y no quiero serlo entonces que
pensamos el traje es un 135 siento
siento que está en el medio para mí solo
porque es una jugada segura entendido sí
creo que cuando se trata de estilo la
intención es lo más importante es como
los puños de su camisa la forma en que
los enrollo esto es muy interesante y
diferente pero tiene una visión deberías
estar entre el revés e induce hoy vine
porque estaba en plan ya sabes hoy
quiero ponerme mi mejor momento
me siento más yo cuando estoy
completamente vestido es una expresión
de cómo me siento por dentro y también
por fuimos clasificar como diríamos
entre todos para ver cuál es el promedio
nos ponemos un número si bien de acuerdo
me siento seguro de mi atuendo me siento
el mejor vestido
el traje creo que es moderno es muy
estilizado así que de segundo esta
chaqueta es de un curso y luego entre
ustedes dos me gusta mucho lo limpio que
es eventos zapatos la mezcla del verde
con el toque azul marino en la parte
inferior me gustan los colores serían el
cuarto y el quinto lo acepto tomar el
primero para mí el segundo porque tus
zapatos son geniales se nota que
elegiste con cuidado tu atuendo de hoy
lo único es que no mezclaría los 217
show
el fútbol juntos y es como algo personal
personal tercero sólo porque viniste a
divertirte hoy se no gracias y lo
aprecio yo definitivamente nunca me
pondría algo así pero no puedo criticar
la confianza que hay que tener para
ponerse eso es admirable cuarto quinto
es que parece que tienes como ropa de
trabajo en la parte de arriba y unos
zapatos de moda en la parte de abajo y
eso no me convence espero que se fijen
en los pequeños detalles probablemente
no hice lo mejor en cuanto a joyería o
en la elección de los zapatos bien son
definitivamente es el uno porque vino
con esa intención y se nota te vas a
quedar de primero como tienes un traje
superas a todos y lo sabes voy a
mantenerte de 2 y am y de 3 ustedes dos
son intercambiables los dos tienen la
misma energía me gusta tu borra porque
dice más tarde
estoy clasificando basándome en lo que
yo usaría supongo que tiene sentido para
mí sigue siendo de uno porque estás en
otro nivel pero me pondré dedos porque
me gusta mucho mi propio estilo para ser
realistas aceptaría el 3 por el traje
aunque no es lo mío el traje me queda
bien pero es como ver un catálogo de
sara tú de cuatro y cinco muy bien de
acuerdo los pondré de
1 2 y 3 aprecio el traje sabes por james
bond hacia el hombre lo aprecio de
cuarto creo que estaría bien y te puse
ahí porque siento que me vería demasiado
alto me diría como dos metros y medio
así que te imaginás con el atuendo teto
exacto es decir me pongo en el lugar de
ustedes me sitúo de quinto porque
todavía me siento seguro en esta
posición puedes calificar td5 y gusta
estar aquí es como estar en el cero no
eres una gigante esta línea no lo es
pero cómo te sientes con tu atuendo creo
que me veo bien
sexy pero no de una manera extraña
es como como la pizza malo pero ya sabes
bueno a la vez eso es lo que siento
saben de joven solía ser muy inseguro
porque parecía una una pelota y no me
sentía para nada bien
la ropa era un escape una forma en la
que podía lucir mejor así que este es el
orden en el que nos vamos a poner esto
es esto es nuestro sitio
creo que está bien es decir creo que
esto es un promedio sólido todos nos
vemos así que es lo que es
pueden ponerse los audífonos
[Música]
muy bien chicas comencemos
personalmente siento que cualquiera
puede usar un traer un tercero cuando
pienso en el mejor vestido y en un
hombre el traje es lo primero que me
viene a la mente creo que tal vez habría
sido genial que él saliera de la caja
eres libre de pensar eso yo yo lo
pondría de primero pero ese es mi estilo
es lo que me gusta siento que quizás les
gusten unos buenos cigarrillos
amo el azul y el marrón su cinturón hace
juego con los zapatos para mí eso es muy
importante se esforzó con los detalles
no solo se puso el traje y como él dijo
hay una intención la intención y el
traje lo pondría de según segundo tercer
segundo tercero miente de acuerdo pero
que pensamos del número un grado que
busco más lo que me atrae y
personalmente no me atrae respeto sus
selecciones pero no es para mí
personalmente para mí la practicidad y
la moda van de la mano sinceramente me
atraen las cosas tradicionales y esto
era muy avant garde para mí
probablemente lo pondría de cuarto
yo difiero está bien
siento que john tiene el segundo mejor
atuendo en la habitación
pero es alrededor de un estilo tan que
sí vieron su maquillaje también lo de
ver delineado el rojo expresión hay que
tener confianza para salir y ponerse lo
que uno quiere me encantaría que fuera
el primero me gusta que los chicos usen
cosas porque les representan y no porque
esté en demos a exámenes hacerlo el de
flores el número el de gorra roja
debería ser el segundo entendido me
gusta que haya coordinado los colores sé
que dijeron que los deportes no
coinciden yo no me habría dado con el da
vueltas de los deportes esas cosas la
verdad es que tampoco me gusta cruzar
marcas a no ser que sea algo lujoso es
la acepción pero si me pongo adidas no
me pongo nike y le gustan las camisas
verdes o el de camisa verde eso suena
forzado sentí que podía acercarme hablar
con él y que estaba bien vestido pero no
me intimidaba lo que creo que es una
línea muy fina en la podemos apreciar
sus accesorios
y yo creo que el de la camisa verde ganó
para mí mencionó que se sentía un poco
sexy tiene un escote y es muy guapo y
luego el de marrón me gusta en los
zapatos me gusta el pequeño toque rojo
me fijé en eso no sé si alguna vez me
pondría esa gorra pero sin dudas es algo
que resalta y vale la pena hablar de
ello me da muchas vibras de estilo
urbano y me encanta lo versátil que es
su atuendo para mí sería el segundo cómo
vamos a reorganizar los tenemos
claramente diferentes gustos de lo que
usaríamos particularmente para mí o seis
meses más así que creo que porque es
básico y el de la camisa verde nos dio
todos esos accesorios fue como si nos
diera su mejor atuendo para días comunes
camisa verde ven al frente creemos que
el de camisa verde es el primero quiero
decir es uno de los dedos pero estamos
de atarlo con que jon es el número uno
no son puede quedarse en beniel de
flores puede seguir allí el de gorra
roja como cinco que piensan
creo que yo no estoy de acuerdo
creo que el de gorra roja debería ser el
número 3 en esto quieres poner al de
traje de cuarto es que no lo sé si
opinión impopular amiga todos mis amigos
son drag queens y yo soy gay no me gusta
mucho la moda masculina revisa mi
opinión con una lupa creo que el de
traje es mejor que el de gorra roja así
que lo mantendría ahí bien entonces
decidamos entre el 4 y el si no lo sé
sigo diciendo que lo cambien al 5 no lo
sé si gorra roja el 5 y gorra roja al 5
yo los cambiaría si cambiemos los
ustedes deben cambiar
bien
es un buen punto medio entre todos sí
seguro me convencieron
todo así
no
[Música]
ahora sube de nivel y fue bastante
interesante no pensé que estaría que
arriba de hecho
también me sorprendió
pero no me sorprendió que john quedara
veloz pero sacro me extraña en absoluto
no creo necesariamente que jon fuera el
mejor vestido solo que llamó la atención
le puse cariño a mi atuendo intenté
coordinar los ganchitos incluso incluso
me hice las uñas a juego con las flores
pensé en todos los detalles quizás se
dieron cuenta de eso y me alegro que lo
hicieran pensé que los zapatos me iban a
empujar hacia arriba sinceramente pensé
que estos zapatos ayudarían me los puse
hoy y dije sí estoy a punto de hacer el
número 2 por lo menos aunque pongas
mucha más intención detrás a veces no se
nota lo que estás pensando creo que
pensaron que un traje era una apuesta
segura y que no me arriesgue demasiado
mientras que en mi mente siento que me
arriesgue al usar un traje con patrón y
el tipo de ajuste más atrevido y ceñido
mi estilo es usar ropa de trabajo pero
de forma sexy eso es lo mío no es para
todo el mundo pero me siento muy cómodo
así estoy listo para trabajar y para una
pequeña cita de día podríamos en un
picnic o algo así a veces recibo
comentarios de odio o algunas personas
se confunden como hoy eres un chico por
qué usas falta estoy perfectamente bien
siendo quien soy al fin y al cabo se
trata de ti y de lo que te hace feliz
jubilee vive intensamente